dallas michael's been a stalwart in the
sox rotation so far this year
since his major league debut in 2012 he
leads all
major league pitchers in ground ball
percentage
third base bon kata and the turn there
for a double play
five to four to three and maybe he'll
face the minimum anyway
there's a high fly ball into left field
camping under that one
is eloy jimenez he'll put the leather to
it and the inning has come to an end no
runs
the one hit erased on the double play
after one ending of play it's the white
sox nothing and the tigers nothing
today's starting pitcher for the tigers
is michael fulmer
michael finally gets to make his second
start of the season
swinging a miss michael fulmer sits him
down his first strikeout of the night
former against his former batterymate
james mccann
swinging a miss back-to-back punch-outs
to start the second from michael fulmer
trying to get the last out of the second
inning engel waiting
the 2-2 he swings and pops it up
playable this time
jonathan scope at second a step onto the
outfield grass makes the catch as he
moves toward first angle
is out and a good inning for michael
former
man on two outs no score third the 1-1
swinging the ground ball deep third
sliding backhand to stop by candelario
pops up long throw got him good play by
jamer candelario
to take extra bases away from abraham
michael former's day probably done and
he's got to be
thrilled with those three innings
three and two coming he struck him out
that thing just fell
right off the table and one gone
this is a really good change again swing
and a miss
there's strike three and the inning is
over three strikeouts for dallas kykel
through the first three innings
daniel norris comes into this on for the
second time the 2-2
swinging a miss fastball running up and
away what a good sequence
strikes out mazara's swinging
oh and two right side clanging off of
krone
and a tag by norris off the scramble to
get the out that is a ridiculous play
by norris and crone is down at first
base i mean that was
a pinball ricochet off of cj
krohn who got laced with that ball
and let's hope he is okay but that was a
really heads-up play by norris so we'll
watch it again it's a rocket
and norris amazingly enough is able to
put the tag on before
danny can get there that's one of the
best plays you'll see a pitcher make
defensively yeah because he wasn't
thinking about protecting himself he was
on a full flat
out dive to get the out and get out of
the inning he was able to do both
and krone is still down my goodness i
mean he
from day one he homered on opening day
he has provided a different offensive
look
for these guys he's gonna need some help
to get off the field
which for detroit this is a big loss he
gave him some power
he also gave him a very good defensive
first base
and the tigers with two away will have
runners at the corner
see if jamer candelario can deliver here
in the fourth
the o2 from kykel fought off the other
way and that's a fair ball
down the right field line goodram will
trot home
candelario hustles for second lugo puts
on the brakes at third and the tigers
are on the board
good job by jamer here he got a steady
diet of those cutters on the inside
but owen too and he came right back in
there again and jamer
kept again kept the barrel of the bat
out and kind of
fought it off and lined it into to right
field probably jammed him just a little
bit but
up enough to fight it off real good job
by jamer
bottom of the fifth travis demerit
leading off here against dallas kykel
first pitch swinging a high fly ball to
deep center field
chasing angle back though he's got a
bead on it makes the catch over the
shoulder
and that very cavernous outfield for
round number one
now the 1-0 pitch on the ground sharply
to short one more time fielder there by
larry garcia quick toss across going to
be in time austin romain out number two
that'll bring up jacoby jones here soft
tapper down the third base line kykel
fields throws and gets jacoby jones
that's five
pitches three outs here in the fifth
inning for
dallas kykel nico goodram
scored that lone run he's been on base a
couple of times
sends one to deep left center get going
angle on the run looking gone nico
goodrum have yourself a night my friend
two
nothing tigers big blast look like a
change up right down the middle of the
plate
nico stays back he's been getting a
steady diet of it almost like hey i'm
gonna wait for it
didn't know it at the second he hit it
if he quite got enough but yes he did
so here's danny mendick come back with
one out of the seventh inning detroit
two white sox nothing
in the left center field swatted by
danny mendick up that expansive alleyway
and he busts it for second base so danny
rounding second going for third he's in
there
head first danny mendick has himself
a one-out triple in detroit
and for danny that is triple number one
of his career
look it's 420 to straight away center we
told you the spacious alleys in this
ballpark
are bigger than most any major league
ballpark
danny takes advantage of it and easily
dives into third base
so adam engel trying to drive in at
least one here against cisnero
on the ground right side and that will
get the run home
mendix scores adam engel gets the rbi
ground out
and the sox get the run right back at
two to one kykel remains in to work the
seventh against james candelario
candelario sends one to right that'll
find the gap
already one double tonight puts on the
after burners he wants three
he's gonna dig for it the relay will not
be thrown
candelario kickstarts the tigers seven
with a triple you know uh they know that
again they can't
power it by them so they're staying
within themselves and wait until the
last second
shooting it the other way and he's done
it twice double in a triple
both to right field it's good hitting
isn't it another multi-hit game for
jamer candelario
reyes sprays it to right that's a base
hit and an rbi
for victor reyes 3-1 tigers
3-2 sizzle to center and that gets by
angle
harold castro will score jones has got
speed
waves them home jacoby jones will score
as well
and inside the parker for jacoby jones
came in a little bit just enough and
jacoby jones just knows that he can get
to it
lines it right up the middle looks like
he's ingalls got a bead on it all the
way
makes a dive gets by him three runs home
here for the tigers in the seventh
three-two pitch on the ground towards
short backhanded there
by goodrum long throw crosses wide but a
tag applied
by candelario and now abreu comes up
hobbling
left hip perhaps or left leg
as he crossed the bag we'll take another
look here
tag being applied and a big
jump leap for the base trying to get
past candelario
and so many things happen and they
always say to you in baseball don't
leap for the bag like that you can uh
jam your ankle jam your hip you just
name it a lot of bad things happen it
looked like
he definitely jammed something hitting
the bed in awkward fashion trying to
avoid the tag
and hit the bag at the same time a lot
of force
on that one look they're looking at his
hip brian garcia will work the ninth
for the tigers brian goins his first at
bat
of the night the one to right field
for harold castro four straight for the
tigers
they win this one 5-1 over chicago
nine and five on the year now for
detroit